Hey,
what's going on is Bill Byrd is time for the Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday.
Monday morning podcast.
Dan Checking in on you.
I'm just checking in on you seeing how your work week is going.
I'll tell you right now,
it is a rainy,
gloomy,
um,
Thursday afternoon out here in Los Angeles.
I'll tell you,
but yo,
we aid the Ray.
This is what happens every year.
It fucking range.
Everything turns green and full like a week.
It looks like Portland,
Oregon out here and absolute paradise and then it just stops raining and then
the sun turns all of that Beautiful Green Shit Brown.
And then the Santa Ana winds over the,
they fucking like a giant nature's hairdryer.
Okay.
Just heats the stuff up and then we have our fires and it's totally 100% normal.
And every fucking year when this place is burning down,
somebody from back east always has to call me up.
You got towed.
You all right.
What's up with those fires out there?
It's what the fuck happens.
Do I call up people in Buffalo every eight though?
Ari?
What?
That lake effect snow.
What's Up With Dad,
What Sofa?
Niagara Falls.
And he said,
we should put a fence there.
Somebodies got to go over
everywhere you live,
there's something that makes them,
you gotta pay a price,
70 degrees,
70 degrees in gorgeous every fucking day.
You guys have seen me since I've moved out here.
You've seen that?
Just,
just the JFK level.
Beautiful Tan,
golden,
golden brown ginger that I am.
When I come to your shows,
when I was living on the east coast,
I mean I was just like,
it was like a fucking Casper.
The friendly ghost.
If he actually got in shaped the fat.
Fuck.
Granted my head was the same size as this,
you know,
but ever since I moved out here,
man,
I'm telling you,
people have really commented.
It's like bill for the first time in your life.
He actually look human now.
I'm still pasty has ever black in his ugly as ever.
Right.
That's my biggie fucking line.
Pasty and his freckled as ever.
Um,
anyways.
Yes.
So this is,
this is one of these days we just want to stay at and eat some stew.
You know,
I love cooking,
but I really hate the fucking music on every how to cook video.
Why does it have to be just,
it's so fucking like perky and everything's going to be great.
Okay.
You know,
why?
Why can't,
you know?
And he ever work in a fucking restaurant in the kitchen.
I don't mean being the fucking good looking fucking
dose.
You invites everybody into the restaurant.
Hi,
how are you?
Maybe you'll fuck me if order the right fucking food,
you know,
not that person.
Okay.
You know,
I swear to God,
so much of beautiful women's game is giving you hope.
How far they can get in the game,
how many times they can go around the board and collect $200 just,
just on hope is,
it's,
it's fucking incredible.
MMM.
Anyways,
I'm talking about,
did you ever work in the fucking kitchen?
All right.
Everybody back there,
you know,
half the people there,
if they don't have a record there about ready to get arrested for something,
there's always some sort of drugs going on.
Um,
it,
it's,
it's just a lot of degenerates in the cooking industry.
I just don't understand.
Or maybe that's why they have such pleasant fucking music.
You always have it stage.
So it was this giant fucking kitchen and somebody is just at home and they're
always just like,
I love making toast.
You know,
when I was a little girl and just toast to me was just,
I mean,
it just brought the family together,
the sound of my mom pushing the toaster buttoned down,
the smell of the bread.
Slowly crunching my dog,
muffin it,
my feet.
I figured on a rainy
Thursday afternoon,
we could recreate some of that.
You know,
I just wanted to somebody to make a fucking pork chop on youtube and talk about
how much blow they did in the fucking eighties and are,
they can't even remember.
They can't even believe that they can remember the difference between pork and
poultry.
They both begin with P and my drug dealer's last name was Phillips.
Um,
so it's very confusing time for me,
but as far as I remember,
sorry.
Um,
anyways,
I worked last night I was down at the comedy and Magic Club on her most of
beach.
Speaking of my lovely nonexistent tamp.
Donald Trump literally looks like he has a halo of hair on his fucking head.
I just don't understand.
Why doesn't he just take they hair plugs are incredible now.
Just take your shit from the back in paratroop that shit.
I Dunno.
It's like he has said,
remember when Justin Bieber had like that comb over hair cut,
which I really found offensive as a balding man.
You know that some would mark my situation with a full head of hair and I'll be
honest with you,
I don't think I ever quite forgave him for that.
MMM.
Anyways,
I'm sorry,
I'm,
I'm all over the fucking map here.
What was that just talking about?
It's talking about people doing blow in the backs of kitchens,
right?
No,
it was past that.
Alright.
You know what it,
it just,
Oh,
I was down her most of the beach doing a show with a blobby call and Bobby
Collins.
We did a show down there after raise some money for a great charity.
Went down there,
tried out a bunch of new stuff.
If you guys are in La,
if you want to go to a great comedy,
I love that fucking place.
And the people who run it and the level of like comedy Mike Memorabilia that
they have down there is a,
is incredible.
I believe that guy told me that,
uh,
he has something of George Carlin's at George War on one of the specials,
right?
And like a window or something like that.
I'm almost afraid to say it.
Some fucking lunatic ticket.
Go down there and try and steal it,
but it's,
it's really incredible.
It's like a,
it's like performing in the standup museum.
Especially when you saw how old my jokes were.
Sorry.
All right,
let's talk about the Boston Bruins.
Shall we bill all Billy freckles?
I am back on the fucking bandwagon here.
Jesus Christ can somebody closer to him and they fucking flushed the toilet
there.
Um,
um,
I watched the Columbus game,
which we lost in overtime.
I miss last night,
which we also lost in overtime,
but we still picked up two points.
All right.
We got a lot of people out.
Evidently like the injury bug is not only hit the fucking Bruins,
it's also hit the Celtics.
Kyrie Irving is messed up his knee.
He was about supposed to be out for a few games.
Now they're saying it looks even worse.
So I don't know what that means.
You know,
the Celtics are not disclosing how he hurt his knee,
but I think we all know,
okay,
Kyrie thinks the world is flat and he was walking like it was flat and all of a
sudden he got towards starts to,
you know,
go down a little bit.
And you know,
it's like you ever walked down the stairs and you think you're at the last one
and you're not,
you know,
you miss a stair for something like that or you think you're at the end and
you're not.
I think he did that walking around his house just thinking,
well,
the earth's flat.
I don't need to adjust to the circumference here.
And that's how he hurt his knee.
And that's a true story.
But Ted Denato of the Bruins,
Ted Denato have,
it's Ted Denato.
Oh,
sorry,
Ryan didn't,
I don't want to,
I'm sorry.
I'm old son of Ted Denato came up with the Bruins is first frigging game.
He scored a goal and had two assists in a a overtime loss.
I believe it was five to four against Columbus was great.
But what's his face?
Bershire Ron was saying that he actually,
when he was 18 played with Ryan's dad and Ryan was just a kid and would come to
practice and would skate around as a little kid and now all of a sudden he's on
the team.
Um,
I think they said version one runs 32 years old.
Yeah,
right around that age.
That's when that type of shit starts happening.
You know what I mean?
And it's like you just remember somebody being like four years old and next
thing you know you wake up and you're doing like Tequila shots with that little
fucking four year old being like,
how are you of age?
When did you turn 21 and the person will be like four years ago,
you know,
like you are 25.
Yeah,
I got a kid.
You're like,
what the,
what the fuck happened?
And what happened was,
is you stopped growing.
There's no more grades,
erotic college.
Once you pass 22,
all right,
that's this weird fucking phase until you get,
until you get married and have a kid of your own.
If you Jiffy of like me and you just went all the way into your forties and
never got fucking married and never had a kid,
um,
you live in like this fucking Peter Pan Lifestyle where you like,
you still acting like you're 23 and then all of a sudden someone who was too is
now 25 and they're actually married and they have a kid you like,
what the fuck?
What am I doing?
And um,
if you like me,
it just causes you to drink more.
I mean,
why would you sit there and like,
you know,
as an adult and try to address just exactly what the fuck are you doing with
your life?
Um,
you know,
but it's fun.
It's fun staying out there for 15 years longer than you should have.
You stick all the stories you have.
Maybe that's why that pleasant music bothers me.
Maybe those people who would make those,
those cooking videos,
maybe they got married at like 25 when they were quote supposed to.
Okay.
You know,
so they didn't,
you know,
they just stay out there too long.
Get all fucking jaded
like uncle Frankel's here.
Right.
Um,
I'm supposed to mention this.
Okay.
Second shows have an added from my,
uh,
my tour,
my turnage 50 tour,
uh,
this year.
Uh,
and the following cities.
A second show has been added.
Maher match dirty first in like a lamb.
I'll like a fucking feature.
Um,
March 31st San Antonio,
Texas,
uh,
stars at night are big and bright.
Bup,
bup,
Texas.
Uh,
April six,
Pittsburgh,
Pennsylvania.
Laid show added.
Do.
Let's go to parade means you get the French fries.
Mash it in.
Why am I doing a Boston accent?
Because I'm limited.
Okay.
April 7th,
Cincinnati,
Ohio,
late show added baby.
If you ever wondered,
wondered how you're ever going to get tickets to my show,
they added it up.
Fucking show in Cincinnati to come on down and see my red nuts.
Tell show,
tell jokes.
Sorry,
Ben Hacking and stealing fucking material from openers.
Feature acts and headliners.
Nash.
Oh,
Nashville,
Tennessee second show added April 21st uh,
let me tell you a story about a man named Gary Paul.
Mark neighbor kept fame,
paid solely blame black people and screamed at the Jews.
I made an evil flag.
No.
What you going to do?
Nashville?
That is,
yeah,
the predators and hillbilly.
Um,
alright.
Minneapolis,
Minnesota.
June 29th,
late show added,
um,
Wayne bump,
bump bump.
What songs that it's a prince song.
Wait at that.
Duh Duh Duh.
Motherfucker.
Something.
Something was that soft and wet.
That's my abs after one.
Sit Up.
Oh.
July 14th,
fucking Portland,
Oregon in me.
Then I added an organic late show for you.
Gluten free.
Fucking Harry comes up there.
Um,
uh,
July 17th,
Seattle laid show added.
Alright.
In honor of the only guy left the live up here.
He,
her,
I entered fucking freaking from wound and shared.
Oh well gerd.
Um,
nine 30,
September 30th to those of you not in Europe.
Um,
Denver,
Colorado,
second night.
Second show at Rocky Mountain had Colorado experimental aircraft.
John Denver,
you know,
if he was wearing his puffy coat around his head,
maybe he still owe a third show at it.
Sorry.
Why am I making fun of John Denver?
I always liked that guy.
He was always great on the muppet show.
You know,
that's not an easy show.
Everybody says don't perform with kids or animals.
What about puppets?
You know,
I was always a tough one.
He could fucking just sitting there talking to a God damn puppet,
right?
The TV screens on you and the puppet and then you're just,
you're sitting there and you're looking down.
You can see the puppeteer.
He's up there doing the fuck.
He's down there doing the voice and the whole time you're trying to remember
your lines,
you're like,
that's what the guy who does fucking Fozzie bear looks like.
So fucking weird.
I never pictured picture.
I'm looking like that,
John.
If it's your line,
this is the 12th take.
Can you get through the fucking take here?
Um,
anyways,
I want to thank everybody who's been coming out all right and buying tickets to
my show.
I'm turning a half a century old.
You understand that everything on me is 50 years old.
It's incredible.
By this whole fucking mess of a human being is somehow survived for 50 years.
Hey,
Belle.
Hey Belle,
his to 50 more.
Here's the 50 more are,
do you know how to do math,
sir?
Hey,
people do that.
here's do another 68 do another 60 that would make them one 20 this couple,
you know the odds of one of them making it there is,
is astronomical.
Forget about both of them.
Just do another 60 when you say that what you're really doing in a passive
aggressive way is letting people know that they're on the,
they're on the back night,
they're going to die.
They bell.
Here's to another 50 I mean,
I guess I could make a hundred.
I mean,
what's the world going to look like at that point?
A bunch of robots fucking telling me what to do.
They could have no sympathy for me.
You think people don't respect human beings in this country?
Don't respect their elders.
You wait till the robots come around.
Metal counts.
All right.
Uh,
I got to do a little advertisement here.
I have you guys been watching the match madness?
I write my bookie.
All right.
I love my book.
You know why?
Cause they're not ashamed that they're a bookie.
Unlike those other people who had,
or were there others,
people,
Dream Weavers,
whatever the fuck they call and try to say,
oh,
it's a game of skill.
No,
it isn't.
You're taking your hard earned money and you let it fucking ride and you're
either going to come out this weekend where in some Elvis rings or you're going
to be sucking Dick down on some fucking boulevard in my book.
He is not afraid to let you know that they're,
they're a part of that world.
To all my listeners,
if you're,
if you already busted your bracket,
there's still a way for you to cash in on March madness.
Sorry,
I thought that was the end of the sentence.
Cash in on March madness at my bookie.
If you haven't signed up yet,
it's not too late.
It doesn't matter if you've been a player for years or you like a team because
their colors matched your favorite shoes.
Lay down some money and score big on college hoops.
A join me and thousands of online players that start betting.
They actually gave me some free money to bet.
I got a bet that shit they gave me 500 bucks.
You guys give me a picks.
Gimme a picks and I'm going to throw it on there and if somebody gives me a
winner,
I'm giving you the money.
What do you think about that at my bookie Agee.
Are you sick and tired of getting the run around when you're asked for a payout?
Come join my bookie today.
I would only recommend a service that's been good to me and my listeners.
Why are they putting words in my mouth?
I've never fucking used it.
I just liked the fact that they've owned up to the fact that they're in the
gambling world.
Uh,
that's why evidently I'm telling you,
that's why I'm reading this that says,
I'm telling you to make your way to my bookie.
You when they pay fast,
when without hassles.
Well,
there's the other side.
If you lose,
you pay sneaky motherfuckers.
You're wasting your time.
Bedding,
anywhere else they even,
they even have live in game bedding.
So you can place a bet after tip off.
Oh Jesus.
How exciting is that?
A join now and my bookie will match your first deposit posit with a 50% bonus.
Use Promo Code burpee you are are to activate this offer,
visit my bookie.
Dot.
Agee today.
Play when and get paid.
Hey,
um,
then spend chat and get late.
That's how it's going to work.
Okay?
No matter what,
you're going to fucking spend your money.
Um,
I got 500 bucks to play with,
I believe.
Once you guys pick me some winners,
I'm going to put some money on the Kansas Jayhawks.
That's always been my team.
I really got into college hoops in the 90s,
and I just Kansas and um,
let's save.
Always stuck with me.
I just fucking lie.
That's think it's,
I don't know.
I just always liked the Jayhawks.
All right.
Trump moves to crack down on China trade with $50 billion in Ti olive oil.
You have like the Christopher Walken pauses,
the weird pauses,
drop moves to crack down on China.
Try Aid.
I can't just walk in with 50% tariffs on imported products.
Um,
he's basically imposing this tariff evidently because in the past he's claiming
a chain of forced,
I guess the u s to sh to show them how we make shit.
I don't know if this is true,
but you know,
everybody's steals,
right?
Everybody steals,
um,
you know,
like,
it's like,
Hey Pepsi,
where'd you get that idea?
Hey for stripe.
Adita what's up with that sneaker?
Nice design.
Doesn't that look familiar?
Let me read this article here.
Let me read out loud to give you an x even more enjoyment here.
President Trump took his first steps towards imposing tariffs on 50 billion in
Chinese goods and limiting China's ability to invest in the u s technology
technology industry.
Now I have the hiccups.
I'm going to plow through the hiccups holding my breath.
Is there a way to scare yourself?
You know,
you scare yourself out of the hiccups.
Don't look at yourself in the mirror until the next time you get hiccups and
just that small amount of time,
the amount that you've aged will scare the shit out of you.
All right?
Maybe not.
All right to invest in the u s technology,
technology,
technology industry,
Thursdays saying the moves were response to Beijing's history of forcing US
companies to surrender their trade secrets to do business in China.
A one,
a four can sell that.
Hey,
you got to show us how you made.
Okay,
it's Kentucky Fried Chicken.
Do they have the fucking secret recipe?
Now
what they have Kung Pao fried chicken.
How do they do it?
That's like their Mcdowell's.
Oh my God,
that's fucking hilarious.
Let me ask you this.
Why is why,
if this is true,
right,
why a fuck is Trump blaming China?
What does he blame all those fucking corporations sellouts who turned over there
fucking secrets.
That's the corporation's fault.
Why don't you draw a line in the sand?
You fucking greedy cunts.
Hey,
if you want to sell that here,
you guys show me how you make it.
You know what,
go fuck yourself.
I remember when I used to sell shit at theaters and if they want it too big,
then when they started,
like all of a sudden they'd be like,
Hey,
well,
you know,
you're kind of using our theaters is a,
uh,
as a store and then they would take,
try to take 10% 20% in the one place that went up to like 30%.
I was like,
yeah,
I'm gonna give you a fucking a third of this.
Go Fuck Yourself.
I'm not doing it.
Then I just stopped.
I stopped selling shit.
That's why I don't go out there anymore.
All right.
Although I am selling a poster on the store,
uh,
the president directed US Trade Representative Robert.
He lightened Heizer.
Yeah.
Jesus Christ is he the great grandson of Robert E.
Lee.
They changed the last name to announce a proposed list of products to be hit
with tariff increases within 15 days after a public comp comment period.
The final list is designed to target Chinese products that benefit from improper
access to us.
Technology will be made public.
The end objective of this is to get China to modify its unfair trade practices.
Says Everett.
Okay.
S e stat,
deputy assistant to the president for international economic affairs.
Well,
why don't they tell the fucking corporations to be,
you know,
to fucking have a little backbone,
get together and be like,
Hey China,
you know,
you,
you wanna,
you wanna you wanna fucking sell these hacky sacks.
We're not going to tell you how we make,
you want to cut it up and try to figure it out.
That's on you.
But I'm not going to sit here and tell you.
I don't know.
Who knows?
Has he met with that guy from Korea yet?
I was so excited about that.
The two fucking world leaders that didn't get along with each other.
Yes.
Sit down and talk it out.
You know,
I some food.
Fight him over.
Um,
come over here.
Show them a good time.
Take them on space mountain then left memories.
There will be a,
I can't blow that up.
I had a good time.
I met fucking Donald Duck and went on space mountain.
You know,
I gotta,
I gotta I gotta fucking hand job on and I,
they have dead fucking pirates of Penzance,
right.
Whatever the hell it is.
The Johnny Depp One.
Um,
I don't know.
I look forward to it.
I understand it.
You know,
I've been sending everybody that fucking Michael McDonald does iron maiden and
you know,
it kills me.
The amount of people that don't get it,
they were like,
does he always sing like that?
But they don't get,
it's like the,
you have to know iron maid and Michael McDonald.
Do you understand?
That's a wide berth.
If you listen to a word
and the church said
he wished he died,
I mean the odds
for as much as people on social media,
oh,
he's trying to say that they have,
I have an eclectic,
okay.
ECLECTIC taste in music.
Do remember that on my space.
One person said that and then all of a sudden everybody was using that.
I have very eclectic taste.
It was just as fucking way,
you know,
it's deliberate,
carefully planned out way to show how fucking interesting you are.
An open minded right.
Favorite albums,
uh,
back black and muppets take Manhattan.
I mean,
I'm all over the map.
Okay.
I don't see color man.
I actually think that social media,
as much as it's helped me go from the obscurities of featuring in comedy clubs
to the heights of telling my shit jokes in three different continents at this
point.
Okay.
Um,
I actually still think it's a bad thing.
Okay.
All right.
Because it before social media,
nobody said Freebie.
There were way less fake tits.
Um,
speaking of which by the,
I can't,
I can't even figure out fucking Instagram.
I finally,
I posted a picture today and then I had to delete it because I,
I thought like the next screen was going to be the thing where you write shit.
So my wife tells me,
okay,
you got to delete it.
So I deleted and then I fucking,
um,
oh.
And then all those filters,
what filter am I going to put on this fucking thing?
And it actually makes you look better than you are.
You should see how green in Austin my shirt looks.
It looks like fucking pea soup and real life.
But in that one,
it look it look rich and bold,
patriotic.
The whole fucking thing is a lie.
But I'll tell you what isn't a lie.
The picture that I took.
Okay.
All right.
With Henry Where Club Stephen Root and Alec Berg and uh,
Bill Hader was supposed to be there,
we were a nerd melt on sunset and they were promoting this incredible new show
that is debuting this Sunday,
March 25th,
I believe at eight o'clock eastern time.
And I'm
yeah,
name of the show's berries,
but this Guy Barry,
he's an ass,
he's a veteran from the Afghani war.
And when he comes back to the states,
a becomes a hit man and one of his hits is in La.
He goes out to la and it's a long story.
He ended up catching the acting bug and he's trying to transition out of
being a hitman and becoming an actor.
And I can't even tell you how in such a dark comedy,
it's such a funny fucking show.
I cannot recommend this shown up.
They sent me four episodes.
All right.
And I am Jonesing for the last,
for the writing,
the acting,
everything.
You have to fucking watch this show.
You have to watch this show.
You do not.
You come back on Monday,
you have,
you do fucking stare at the floor.
You don't say good night to nobody.
Pope of Greenwich Village or anybody.
Um,
what am I?
Some kind of fucking asshole.
What Bank?
Um,
so anyways,
those three people and Bill Hader was supposed to be there and I was reading up
on everybody.
So,
uh,
cause I haven't done a lot of these energy types of things.
So I was reading up on Bill Hader and they said how um,
one interesting fact about him,
he is the voice for the planner,
peanut guy,
even though he has a peanut allergy.
So I'm sitting in the back thinking like,
Holy Shit,
I'm going to meet Henry Winkler it,
my goal in this hour long interview is not once am I going to bring up happy
days or the fonts,
right.
Steven roots there.
I'm not bringing up that fucking red stapler.
I know both of these guys have answered these questions 4 million fucking times.
I want to talk about the present and how amazing this God damn show us.
And um,
so I'm waiting for everybody to come in and at the last second,
right before,
you know,
I'm nervous to do this interview.
I haven't,
you know,
he's a big fucking people and a,
and Alec Berg worked,
worked on like two of my favorite shows,
um,
Caribbean throughZ ASM and silicone valley,
both high high level comedies.
And I was,
you know,
like I said,
a little intimidated to meet all these people and right before I'm going to go
out there,
they show up and they say,
Bill Hader can't make it.
He,
uh,
somebody puts some peanuts,
shit,
like some all almond milk and he's fucking Starbucks coffee and his throat was
swollen up.
He's fine.
The man is fine.
Um,
so now I'm sitting there like,
oh fuck.
Like I had so many questions to ask him and I'm not talking to Henry Winkler
about happy days or Steven rude about the red state though.
What the fuck am I going to do?
And fortunately they were such great guests.
They actually sort of carried me,
was on Sirius Xm and there was um,
I learned so much about acting and writing just talking to them.
Uh,
the through line with the three of them are just how open they were.
And um,
Henry Winkler has this,
this,
this combination that I've never seen.
I think I've ever seen it.
He's like the warmest,
nicest guy while being unbelievably driven
and just has giant balls as far as like,
you go in there,
you make you fucking choices.
There is no wrong choice.
I don't give a fuck if this choice acting choices going to make me look stupid.
I'm totally committed to it.
Usually people like that,
that driven with that much courage and all of that.
Like literally they can be really a abrasive when you meet him,
you know that just push and passion.
He's like the Nice fucking guy ever.
And listening to him talking about the like in the fact that he went in and you
audition for it and all of that,
he wasn't sitting there going,
hey,
I'm a fucking TV legend.
You should be happy to get me.
He went in and auditioned for Steven Roots.
Another guy,
same thing talking about you go in,
you fucking audition,
you know,
and I was getting advice from other people going,
hey man,
you're at a certain,
once you were at a certain level you don't go in and read,
you know you should be getting offers like that fucking Hollywood shit.
And I talked to two of them.
You don't get better than those two guys.
And they both told me if you want the part you go in and read for it.
And I was just like,
there is a fucking gem right there that I'm never going to forget.
So thank you to the two them for telling me that.
And then Alec was talking about,
um,
writing,
which was fascinating to me because I've gotten to do it for the last three
seasons on f is for family.
And uh,
up untilF is for family,
I always wrote for myself,
so I heard it,
I wrote it and then I said it the way I heard it.
And then all of a sudden on f is for family,
I hear it a certain way and then we go to the table read and an actor does it
another way and there's a thing where you gotta be like,
he can't be like that asshole going like,
oh wait,
you're supposed to clear your throat first and do it exactly the way I hear.
You have to have that thing where you just have to be open to the way they do
it.
And thank God.
Thank God.
I,
I think I kind of figured that out certainly with the fucking actors that we got
on an f is for family.
It's like,
I'm not going to tell these people to do anything any other way than the way
they're doing it.
Um,
but just the way,
Alec,
I hope you guys can,
I don't know how it works.
If you can go on Sirius Xm and downloaded the interview,
it seems like everything you didn't,
you didn't,
you didn't have a miss anything anymore because it's still available.
But,
um,
long story short with all this meandering is that show comes out this Sunday
and,
uh,
Bill Hader soon.
All this like,
you know,
it's not just a straight up comedy like it's a really like dramatic dark show.
It's,
um,
I dunno,
it Kinda has everything that I love and it reminded me of one of my favorite
comedies.
I mentioned this a zillion times.
It's like midnight run.
And I just loved that movie because
okay.
Like it's crazy as it got,
everything was still rooted in a reality and it had a lot of heart and all of
that type of stuff.
And I,
and this show has that,
I'm telling you,
I'm calling it right now.
That shows going to be a big hit.
And I hope you guys tune in to watch porn.
It's fucking Bill Hader,
Stephen Root,
Henry Winkler.
I mean,
you can't go wrong.
You can't go wrong with that.
Um,
and the rest of the cast to the actors in the acting class that he gets into,
um,
are all incredible.
Uh,
all right.
I don't want to oversell it,
but definitely check it out when you're not betting with my bookie on March
madness.
Oh,
it brings it all around.
All right,
well that's the Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday.
Monday morning podcast.
Thank you guys for listening.
Have a wonderful weekend.
[inaudible] please enjoy the music.
And then there's another 30 minutes of a greatest hits Thursday from,
I dunno,
Thursday,
10 years ago or whatever,
four years ago,
four weeks ago.
I don't fuck,
I don't know how it works.
All right,
that's it.
I'll talk to you on one.
What's
going on?
It's Belper and this is the Monday morning podcast and the levels are a little
too high.
Let me bring it down.
Bring it down for you,
mother fall calls.
Hey,
how are ya?
It's a March 25th a Thursday.
And I know what you're thinking.
Where the fuck was the podcast?
Um,
on the 22nd that was in Europe and I brought my recorder but I've got the wire.
yeah,
so I fucked up,
but you know what,
where we're going to get through this,
my 14 listeners that I'm back down to over the,
this rough seven week fucking period as I try to get this thing back up and
running again.
Um,
I do have a new web guy and um,
he is since uploaded all of the podcasts from the beginning of time,
which is time began as far as I'm concerned in my podcast.
Religion began in June of 2007.
All right.
With one of my apostles,
Robert Kelly setting it up in his apartment.
So all the podcasts,
this is what we're working on right now.
Okay.
And all you guys,
you sending me emails and everything in the trash for me and shit and uh,
I actually appreciate the trashing because that means you care.
All right?
So don't worry.
Actually,
by the time you fucking listening to this thing,
when you actually find it,
the problem is over.
Okay.
Uh,
but for those of you who are actually in the bunker and have been able to find
this fucking podcast,
um,
basically,
uh,
we're going to have it all up on iTunes right now.
I have like three different icons or whatever the fuck you spoke apps,
whatever the hell you call him,
you that you can click on.
One is the old school podcast with [inaudible].
The other one is the one that I did on Libsyn for like fucking three weeks.
And I hated that.
And now I have my new one that I created.
I didn't create,
I paid someone to create it.
See,
I'll see the white man does,
takes credit.
Um,
anyways,
um,
that I paid for someone else to create that I will now take the credit for and
banish the person who created it to some terrible duty,
like they're doing the police.
Um,
and I'll take all credit for it,
but there's going to be going to be one icon.
Okay.
This is what we're working towards.
And it's taken a while because we had to upload a couple of fucking years worth
of podcasts and a,
it's all going to be on one icon and you're going to click on,
it's going to be the Monday morning podcast from right now all the way back to
the beginning of time.
And I'm slowly starting my own religion because,
uh,
those guys,
they don't get in trouble and they make a ton of money.
You know,
he fucking raped 16,000 fucking kids and uh,
you know,
no one's going to jail as far as I know,
maybe a couple of people are.
I don't really,
you know,
I didn't really follow the story.
You know,
I just heard people talking about it last night at the Improv and then I fucking
throw my 2 cents in to the ad to the misinformation.
But anyways,
all this shit is going to be a,
it's all gonna be under one umbrella,
so it'll be nice and easy,
big stupid picture of myself and we'll be back to normal.
Okay.
We had a little blip and our relationship,
okay.
You know,
that happens in all relationships.
every once in a while for a couple of weeks,
maybe you move out,
get your head straight,
maybe sleep on the couch a couple of nights.
That's what's going on here.
Nothing else.
All right.
I haven't quit doing them.
But you know,
you know,
the one thing that has remained constant is I have been continuing to do the
podcast,
granted,
you know,
two,
three weeks to three days late on this one when I was over in Scotland,
Dublin and London,
London,
England.
And um,
but before I get into all of that,
I'm a fan of the podcast,
actually started a podcast page where you guys can go on there and look at some
of my obscure references or look at the words that I mispronounce or whatever
else.
I'm actually putting some questions on there that I want you guys to start
answering and I'll read them here on the podcast.
What's the name of the site?
Good fucking question.
I don't have it in front of me.
I'm winging it this week.
It's a m M podcast.com I believe.
Let me actually do this right now.
So I know I'm really gonna wing this one.
Uh,
this is all going to be off the top of me.
Head Christ said isn't even coming up and man podcast.
So what the fuck it is?
Hang on.
I'm typing with my middle finger.
Enter.
What do we got?
You fucking cunt.
That isn't it.
How about the,
Oh,
you suck.
You know what?
I'm the fucking worst.
Is it really that bad that people can't find this fucking podcast when I can't
even have the fucking decency to be three days late and actually be prepared?
That's what it is.
I got in,
I found it,
uh,
and I spelled it all right.
It's,
it's,
this is,
this is the fan page.
It's the m M podcast.com.
That's what you want to go to.
And then you click it on and there's a picture of me and my fucking shaved head
and a big fucking picture of big foot.
Um,
and then you scroll down and they got all the shit that I've,
that I've been talking about,
um,
on here and it's just going to keep getting bigger and bigger.
That's what we're hoping for.
Gives you something else to do,
rather than be at your fucking job hating your life.
That's what this podcast is all about.
It's all about getting you through that first fucking awful day of the week,
which is why,
and me of scoring my dates out in my stuff and trying to become a silent
millionaire.
Um,
what does this silent millionaire,
I'll tell you what it is.
It's,
it's a fucking term that I just invented.
What do think about that?
You know,
I could do that on this podcast.
Oh,
speaking of which,
Robert Kelly,
one of the creators.
Other podcasts.
Hang on a second.
Bobby Kelly.
Yup.
Nothing.
I'm actually doing my podcast and I was talking about,
I was just talking about how you fucking,
uh,
helped me create the thing over in your apartment back in the beginning of time.
I'm doing it right now as we speak,
but,
uh,
your voice is up against my ear,
so you're still a,
you know,
you can just talk about shit that we don't need people to know about unless you
want to be.
Why didn't I fucking have you on when any of my podcasts?
When do you go back to New York?
Oh,
you fucking son of a bitch with your career.
What's the deal?
How are we going on a hike today?
It's the gayest thing I've ever said on the podcast.
Um,
what's the deal?
Yeah,
one o'clock is good.
Let me finish running my mouth and I'll see you over there,
right,
right.
Bobby,
I'm doing a podcast and I'm boring people right now.
I'm going to meet you there.
All right.
We'll go rollerblading afterwards.
Okay,
I'll see you there at one.
Yeah,
he hung up on me like he should have.
Um,
that's right.
I'm going on a hike with Robert Kelly.
I'm bringing in a fanny pack.
I don't give a fuck.
I'm gonna wear a headband.
Maybe tie a Bandana around one of my pasty thighs,
like Chachi on happy days.
Maybe I'll do that shit.
I don't give a fuck.
It's the west coast.
Nobody's paying attention.
This is not reason to,
you know why nobody pays attention.
Do you realize we are at the end of the fucking day,
not only,
not only in this country are we at the end of the fucking day.
Okay.
The,
they'll the world.
By the time we're done talking shit in a bar,
the sun's already coming up in Japan starting the following fucking day.
We haven't gone to bed yet.
Is it any wonder?
Everybody out here seems flaky.
Do you know if I wake up at nine,
nine 30 out here?
It's already mid day back east.
Yes.
Bill.
We can do the math.
Well,
some people can't,
you know.
So what is the fucking point of me getting up and watching the news or reading a
newspaper?
Because it's going to talk about yesterday and it's already fucking today and
back east.
It's already fucking beyond halfway through the fucking day.
That's my excuse.
Um,
so anyways,
uh,
this is the Monday morning podcast and I'm doing here on a Thursday.
I will be doing another one on Monday.
I'll get caught up.
All right.
Don't get mad.
Don't act like you guys.
Don't get behind in your lives.
You know,
stuff starts to mount.
you can't deal with it.
So you take a pill and then the next day,
you know,
maybe I'll take two pills and the next day you now you're fucking drooling on
your fucking lazy boy.
That's how it goes down.
I don't even know what I'm going to talk about this week.
Well,
let's talk about my trip to Europe.
Um,
it was unbelievable.
It was an incredible success.
Uh,
I don't know what the fuck it was.
I don't want as a one over there.
Had a great time and people showed up and I had a great time.
Uh,
the first place I went to was I went to,
um,
I went to London,
England and uh,
I've always wanted to go there and I have to admit,
I,
when we landed at a Frau Ah,
Yay,
am sweating me roasting,
baking,
boiling.
It's like a sona.
I saw him,
I'd hey fro,
Yay.
Did a date night.
I saw him at a frau.
Sorry.
Anytime I say Heathrow I have to say hey fro,
and then I just start doing lines from sexy piece.
Cause I love that fucking movie.
You know,
I love that movie because they,
it's,
it's the best fucking a chick flick ever.
I've said this before and I'll fucking say it again.
Okay.
Next time you girls like,
I swear like a romantic movie.
I'd like to see something.
You know it,
it's been watching too many of these action movies.
It's like,
I don't like him,
but I just want some difference in that kit.
Can I pick an APP?
Okay.
Can I pick it up?
Like you didn't fucking pick out every other one.
Your fucking Twat.
You know what?
Let me step up to the plate sweetheart.
All right.
Once you unbutton another button on your fucking shirt,
give me a little excitement on the way of the fucking video store and I'll pick
out the romantic movie and you come out with sexy beast.
Oh my goodness.
Sexy scandal.
This,
this isn't like a nine and a half weeks now,
bitch.
It's a fucking love story.
Why do you guys have to call me that?
Because you are a bitch.
No,
sorry.
Um,
okay.
That's a fucking great stories about a guys do just,
he loves his woman and he has his own fucking place in the middle of nowhere and
everything's going fucking gray.
Basically every,
if you ever watch a gangster movie,
uh,
you know,
one of the reoccurring themes to the point that now it's become cliched is,
is always the guy who is just going to do one more job and then he's getting
out,
you know,
same thing in the Vietnam movies.
I got one more toward,
dude,
I'm short.
I shouldn't be on point on.
Right.
And you know what the fuck's going to happen to him.
And,
uh,
he didn't believe though the Wayans brothers and one of their movies made fun of
those,
uh,
those fucking around the way movies where there's the black guy who kid who's
going to fucking go to college,
you know,
and he stayed strong.
He didn't get in the game and then he walks up and he's fucking eating some ice
cream and he gets shot in an alley or some shit.
I don't know what the happens,
you know what I mean?
Um,
so anyways,
this movie actually is about a couple of guys who succeeded.
They did their last job,
they got their money and they got out of the fucking game and they're living in
Spain.
They're married to a couple of hot fucking bra and a,
they don't have any kids.
So it's great.
And you know what you're doing when you don't have any fucking kids and you're
married to a hot,
broad,
you're still fuck.
And your barbecue and your lay next to your pool gone.
I,
Yay.
I'm sweating.
Roast and bake and boil it just fucking chilling out,
having a great fucking time.
That's where the movie begins.
And then
trouble ensues and go fucking rented.
I love that goddamn movie.
Every time I see it,
it gets better.
So anyways,
we landed at a fro watching telly.
Is this Stan?
I'm sorry.
It's just getting them noxious like the rest of it isn't.
Um,
so,
uh,
we landed at a fro and uh,
we got in a cab,
you know,
and I started driving down the fucking other side of the road.
Huh?
Stereos or the other side.
We really are in England.
Yeah.
And we're driving through and I'm looking at England and in London and you know
what?
I'm not liking it.
I'm like,
look at this fucking Shitty town.
I just,
it just,
it didn't appeal to me.
And I think the real thing was I was jet lagged because I ended up loving it,
but I was fucking really jetlagged and uh,
my girlfriend's going to kill me if I tell this story.
Uh,
this is basically the space.
What happened?
I got a first class ticket over there,
right.
But it was basically from New Jersey to,
to London,
a frail,
um,
airport.
And this is what has happened my entire career.
Every time I get a first class fucking ticket,
which is rare,
I get a first class fucking 10.
Let me answer the answer that question before he get like,
Bill,
you at the point where you fly first class,
you have a,
where you go,
not even fucking close.
Okay.
Most of those people that you see in first class,
they got bumped up because they fly so much,
because I'm going to tell you a fucking first class ticket is 1200 to 1500 bucks
a month.
All right?
So if I buy two of those a month,
that's like an extra,
it's fucking three grand on my credit card as opposed to like fucking 600 bucks,
700 or whatever the two coach tickets and you know that adds up.
All right?
Times 12 months.
That's 36 fucking grand.
Just so you can get on the plane first and fucking stretch your legs out,
right?
So basically the only time I fly first class is,
uh,
is if they hook me up.
Other than that,
I'll fucking sit in the back with my knees against my chest.
I don't give a shit.
I got the whole thing worked out.
This is how I do it.
All right?
First thing I do when I sit down is I take my wallet out of my back pocket
because I'm one of these guys that has like nine years of business cards,
bank receipts,
case Sheesh,
all this shit in my wallet.
And right off the bat it's just so fucked up.
It's fucking on one ass cheek.
So it's fucking messes up behind my back,
my alignment and a,
if I sit on,
sit on it too hard,
it's like sitting on a fucking stone and it makes me bum a little sensitive.
So I take that fucker out,
I stick it in my front pocket,
and then I just make sure every couple hours I get up,
I always get an aisle seat,
which sucks because people are going to crawl over you.
But uh,
you know,
I don't like being that guy.
When I got to take a leak in,
the person next to me has their laptop out and then they do that.
We'll fucking get a first class ticket.
You do have get an aisle seat.
Who's your fucking travel agent?
We just sitting in the middle.
Um,
so anyways,
I get up every couple hours and I do a little mini yoga thing down the back of
the plane.
You know,
I just do it.
I got this little whole stretching routine that I do because I fly so fucking
much.
And that's how much your first class ticket is that I would rather sit in the
back with my wallet in my front pocket doing yoga back near the shitter.
That's how expensive FirstClass is.
So anyway,
so I get this first class ticket from Jersey,
Newark,
New Jersey to uh,
to London in a fro donate,
uh,
London,
England and a,
this is what has always happened whenever I've gotten a first class,
at least half the fucking time when I'm getting,
when I'm flying first class,
it means I'm going someplace that's awesome or the Gig is going to be awesome.
And what always ends up happening is somebody else wants to fucking go.
And then they always go,
dude,
you're giving you first glazed chicken.
You know,
was you anyway?
Like,
you know,
maybe you could just take a biome good to fucking coach tickets.
So basically half the times I've gotten a first class ticket,
I haven't gotten a fly first class.
I'm sitting back there with,
with a manager or a fucking agent or,
or who knows what a buddy who wants to come along to go check out the gig
because it's going to be awesome.
So I never get to fly.
So long story fucking short is a,
you know,
I spent five months on the road getting ready for,
to tape a let it go,
which by the way,
looks fucking awesome.
I was just looking at,
that's my new special coming out.
So anyways,
I um,
you know,
I,
I never get to fly first class,
so I get,
I get,
I just totally lost my train of thought.
So you look@oneweekoffoflumosity.com and uh,
my brain's fucking up.
Yeah.
So this is the deal.
So I got a first class ticket to go to fucking,
uh,
from New Jersey to a London,
right a fro.
And uh,
my girl goes,
I go,
can I go?
Oh,
you're going some place fun.
She only wants to go to the fun places.
She doesn't come to like fucking,
you know,
Pittsburgh when I need her
fucking Madison,
Wisconsin.
She doesn't want to go on those.
I'm going to Mount Miami.
Then all of a sudden it's like,
oh my God,
I love Miami.
Of course you do.
Who Does it?
What do you need from me?
I need you to love Cincinnati.
That's what the fuck I need from you.
Why don't you come on those trips?
That's when I fucking need you.
So anyway,
she's going to Europe,
right?
There's not,
you know,
if there's no fucking way,
of course I'm going to take her.
So this deal,
I spent five months on the fucking road with my knees to my chest,
my wallet,
my front fucking pocket,
going in the back doing fucking yoga because I had to make sure I had a great
special.
And of course they ended up catching a cold and I did my special with dayquil.
That's a whole nother story.
Okay?
So basically,
you know,
41 year old guy,
my body's fucking junk.
This is my first time going to the U K and then over to Dublin and then back to
fucking Scotland.
Uh,
which I believe,
you know,
I'm a little confused.
Well,
exactly.
What is Great Britain and what is the United Kingdom?
It's really fucking confusing.
It got so many goddamn aliases over there.
All right.
As far as I understand,
Great Britain is England,
Wales and Scotland,
and maybe even the top adult,
uh,
of Ireland with a,
the fuck was all those Goddamn fucking fight Belfast.
Okay.
Is that,
uh,
is that the United is the United Kingdom?
That is great.
Britain.
Just England and fucking Wales.
Is that Great Britain or as Great Britain in England,
Wales and fucking Scotland.
Why don't I look at it?
I didn't look it up.
Fuck you.
This is my question for the week.
What it,
what's the difference between the United Kingdom and,
and,
uh,
Great Britain?
Because before I went over there,
I wanted to learn some of the countries over there,
so I didn't come off as a dumb ass American.
Then I found out there was 50 countries and I was like,
all right,
fuck it.
I'll just learn it over to like Greece,
Romania,
Ukrainia,
Lithuania,
all the Amy's Russia,
half of Georgia,
half a Turkey.
And then once you get to Cag is Stan go fuck yourself over the hell are you
saying?
Um,
I was under the impression that England was a country.
And then when I was looking at the names of country,
it didn't say that.
It said Great Britain,
Great Britain is a country.
What does that include and what does the United Kingdom,
the rest of Ireland isn't part of it.
Is it all right?
Yeah,
I dunno,
you little ass fucking pieces of land over there.
Maybe you guys got a band together,
you know,
like a bunch of fucking Cubans coming over here on a refrigerator door floating
over to fucking the keys,
you know,
I don't know.
So anyways,
so this is the deal.
So I get a first class ticket from Jersey day for out London and uh,
my girl wants to go.
So once again,
I'm in that situation,
I mean that situation.
And it's like,
you know what,
I got to put my foot down.
I finally did.
I said,
look,
this is much fun as we're going to have over there and everything.
This is a business trip.
I have to go over there,
I have to be fucking relaxed.
I'm already going to be jet lagged and I have to hit three home runs in a
fucking row.
I got to kill in London,
I got to kill in Dublin and I got to kill in glazed.
Um,
all right,
so as much as you want to run around and go buy some trinkets and shit,
I have to be rested up for this stuff.
So,
uh,
this is the deal.
I will fly coach with you to Jersey.
And then,
uh,
um,
going up first class to England and I put her in the back,
left her in the back and uh,
you know,
there was some rough waters trying to convince her of that.
And I was like,
look,
this is the deal.
I'm gonna go over there.
I'm going to fucking hit.
And then when a I fucking blow up over there,
I'll fly both over there first fucking class.
So,
because my girl's fucking the shit,
she said fine.
Okay.
So I'm like that shit man.
You see that Shit Mack Daddy fucking pimp got what the fuck I wanted and then
this is what's funny.
Two days before we go to leave,
I get hit with this fucking wave of guilt.
Oh wait a second.
By the way.
Um,
I looked into getting her first class fucking ticking.
You know what?
These fucking cunts or they want to like fucking five grand
just from Jersey.
It's fucking ridiculous.
It's so fucking,
it's so fucking ridiculous.
Why is it 1500 to fly 2,800 miles,
but then all of a sudden 3000 miles are a little over 3,300 miles because I'm
going to a different country.
They all of a sudden your foot,
you'll make it like three and a half times the fucking price.
So I can't do that.
I go over there,
I'm going to lose a couple of grant.
So I just,
you know,
fuck it.
She complained.
She complained a little bit and I go,
are you complaining about a free fucking ticket to Europe?
Is that what you're doing right now?
Yeah.
So anyways,
I ended up feeling fucking guilty and a whatever.
So I got her some DVDs.
Ah,
so you finally landed in eighth ro and I,
we get off the plane and I wait for him and shit.
And I noticed that she's,
you know,
kind of giving me the cold shoulder or whatever.
I'm like,
what's the problem?
And I've,
I can't remember how it went because I was so fucking tired and she was pissed
because I didn't go back to see her during the flight,
you know,
come back there and we went,
what were we going to talk about?
I was going to come back to it and be like,
yeah,
hey,
there's just flying coach still suck.
All right.
I was just checking,
you know,
cause it kinda seemed like it's shot from La to,
to New Jersey,
but I was wondering,
maybe it got better.
I'm actually in defense myself.
I tried to go back there,
but they had a,
uh,
a velvet rope.
Okay.
And I'm not saying that they had a bunch of Janet Jackson's CDs there.
They actually had a velvet rope there and I was not allowed to go past there.
And I said,
fine.
All right.
So I got out of that one,
so whatever.
All right.
So he landed a fro and,
uh,
we get in the fucking car,
we drive over to the hotel and I'm just looking at it going,
this looks a little,
a very gray,
very overcast.
And it was disappearing into a lot of gray buildings.
And I'm like,
what the fuck?
I don't like this.
And,
um,
then I,
you know,
and I took a fucking nap and then I woke up and then we did what New Yorkers
fucking do.
All right.
We don't take tours and I do consider myself a fucking New Yorker,
but not,
no,
I don't,
not affiliated with any of their sports teams,
but I lived there for fucking 12 years and I loved it.
And,
uh,
this is what New Yorkers do when we go to a fucking new city.
Public Transportation Baby.
Show me where you fucking subway is and I'll do it that way.
We had a company,
you know,
Big Ben Parliament,
Bang,
zoom.
Then we just walk the fuck around and we find the cool places to go to.
All right.
We don't go to the dumb shit.
Like one of my buddies,
when you go to Dublin,
go to temple bar,
there's the fucking place to go.
Yes,
I'm going to have a drink with some guy from Cleveland.
You fucking moron.
Go where all the tourists go.
I've,
I've never fucking understood why he would go on vacation to then hang out with
a bunch of other douche bags who aren't from where the fuck you're going.
So what,
what experience do you gain there?
What somebody from Rhode Island is like in London?
It's the dumbest shit ever.
Okay.
You want to see a couple of things,
like when I got to admit,
when I saw Big Ben,
it was,
it was fucking awesome.
I've seen pictures of that.
And you know,
I'm a,
I love watching Wimbledon,
Wimbledon.
I for years,
I've been saying Wimbleton yet,
yet another word that I'd been mispronouncing a o n Wimble ton,
but it's Wimble done deal.
And Wimbledon,
they just say it too fucking fast for my dummy or is to pro actually not my
dummy is my brain's too dumb to process the signals from my years.
I think my ears are okay.
But anyways,
um,
so then that's what we did.
So I saw a big Ben and it was just fucking iconic.
Who,
who's the shit all his years watching Wimbledon breakfast at Wimbledon and then
they,
they always show big Ben and um,
it was incredible.
And,
uh,
got a a,
what else the fuck did I do?
Oh,
I know.
I want it to that the,
toward the two,
uh,
the fucking Abbey road studios fell through.
It's a long fucking story.
They couldn't do it Wednesday and by when they wanted to do a Thursday,
I was doing radio and it just didn't fucking work out,
so I'll have to do that next time.
But,
uh,
so it was like,
all right,
that didn't work out.
Um,
I have to go see Royal Royal Albert Hall.
Now for those of you who are led Zeppelin fans,
you know,
the importance of that building.
And if you got there,
there last DVD that came out,
it has this fucking unbelievable concept that they gave at Royal Albert Hall.
And I always wanted to go there.
It's really difficult to save Royal Albert Hall.
And uh,
it was something that was built,
I believe by the Queen Victoria.
Did I just say this?
Queen Victoria is this fucking broad Queen Victoria.
She was into this guy,
uh,
prince fucking Albert and I guess they were unbelievably in love with each other
and the way that they express love was they,
they bought pieces of art with the money from the poor.
That's what they did.
They were so in love that rather than taking all the fucking disgusting amount
of taxes from the poor people and using it to feed them,
they said,
no,
let's spend it lavishly on ourselves
in this unbelievable art collection that we,
and we alone can sit here and stare at it.
It's just fucking,
I dunno,
that whole royalty thing is hilarious to me.
So,
uh,
yeah,
that's what they did.
And uh,
I dunno.
And then Prince Albert,
uh,
he caught the clap,
which evidently was fatal back in the day.
He cheated on her,
but she still loved him.
And uh,
something like that.
I didn't really read the story.
He can look it up.
I don't know what the fuck he got.
He got like,
what did,
what did you die of in the 18 hundreds?
The mumps,
he got to Berkeley,
so he got something.
Okay.
And he was fucking victorie out and the great lawn in some mosquito bit him.
And next thing you know,
he had typhoid fever.
I don't know.
He died suddenly.
So she was overcome with grief.
And a lot of people say she never got over it.
And what she did was she built this big fucking statue of this guy.
Well that actually is not gold plated,
but gold leaf or Fleck,
I don't know what the,
it's as actual fucking gold in it and it's got a big,
um,
opulent roof to it.
So the pigeons can't shit on the guy and you know why yet again,
yet again to express her love for another human being.
Why would you help other human beings?
Let's spend more of the poor money on this.
This,
it's pretty impressive.
Not going to lie to you.
So anyways,
went over,
we saw that shit and they were actually giving a tour of Royal Albert Hall.
So I wanted to go and it was an hour delay.
And my girl hates tours.
She's a fucking New Yorker.
She's like,
oh with God it could folk and figure it out myself bored.
It's a fucking building.
So Mike,
can we just,
can you just for me?
Can we just fucking do this?
So she's like,
fine.
So long story short,
mate,
we ended up going on the bloody Tila and a just so happens that the London
Philharmonic is practicing in there.
I don't know for a Gig later on that night or the next day,
I have no idea what.
So the guy brings us in there and we walk in two boxes down,
um,
from where the queen's boxes.
Okay,
I'm waiting for the beef [inaudible] and butthead laughing.
He said,
Queen Xbox,
um,
the box with a queen sits in the just basically unbelievable seats and we come
walking in and as we sit down and take in basically the most beautiful theater
I've ever seen in my life,
the beauty of the theater,
right as we sit down,
the orchestra begins playing as if they were waiting for us.
And it was so unbelievably beautiful and so overwhelming that my girlfriend
actually started to cry.
So,
and I started laughing at my girlfriend crying because I was actually afraid
that I was going to get emotional.
That's how fucking unbelievable it was.
It was incredible.
And it was in that moment I was like,
fuck this.
I have to see a concert here.
It was in credit and everybody was basically on our tour,
was sitting there with like,
I,
I don't,
I don't have the ability to describe the sound.
It was the most unbelievable sound I've ever heard in my life and it actually
made me less cynical.
That's how beautiful it was.
I actually felt,
I actually,
what the fuck was I going to,
how do I put this?
It was like,
I,
you know,
I'm real cynical when I think of people,
I think that pieces of shit,
they fucking lie.
They're greedy,
they're weak cowardice and all that fucking thing.
And then you just see this group of people and this building,
like everything was perfect.
The p the,
the construction of it,
the,
the way they decorated it and the,
whoever wrote the music and then all the gifted people playing it.
And we was,
it was,
it was fucking unbelievable.
We will all just sitting there,
it was like something that I will never forget.
And then he fucking,
10 seconds later,
the tour guys like,
all right,
we gotta go,
we gotta go.
No one wanted to go.
And then he's like out in the hall,
gone.
And then this wall here was constructed by Henry the fucking eighth.
And it was like nobody gives a fuck.
We want to go back in there and listen to the band.
It was unreal.
So what,
what happened was we've just kept going to these room to the green room where
the queen hangs out and has her royal Bush trimmed or whatever the fuck they do.
And then we would,
we would be in a different part of the theater and we would dip in,
we would,
we would listen to them play again.
And uh,
this is the thing,
you were not allowed to take video in the place,
but,
uh,
fortunately I'm an ignorant American and I didn't give a fuck and I brought a
little,
uh,
when those little flip cameras in there and I actually,
I got some video footage in there that I will be putting up on my website.
Um,
I'm just going to try to edit it all together.
actually follow through on this and make a nice video of my trip to Europe.
But,
uh,
I got to tell you guys something right fucking now.
Okay.
Fuck going to seaworld.
Fuck the San Diego Zoo.
Fuck all of that shit.
Fuck.
Going to Chicago and going to the top of the Sears tower and going to Wrigley
field.
That shit's all going to be there.
You fucking live here.
All right.
No biggie.
You can drive to all of those things.
Let me tell you some saved your fucking money.
Who gives a shit?
It's not worth anything.
Anyways,
get yourself a ticket at some point.
Go look up Royal Albert Hall.
If you're into classical music.
They have,
uh,
they call them prom shows.
I don't know what that was short for,
but uh,
they have like this,
this like month or two,
six week period where they just have all these orchestras come in.
If you're into classical music.
I saw another concert in October.
Jeff Beck is playing there.
You know that guys,
you know,
it's weird.
He's getting up there in years and he's at the Primers,
Korea.
Basically what I'm saying,
if you're a music lover,
at some point in your life,
if you are,
if you have any even into just fucking architecture,
you have to go see a show there.
Okay.
I'm telling you it was fucking unbelievable.
All right.
And that's it.
That's it for that shit.
All right.
Um,
unbelievable.
So I'm going to try to get back their book a Gig and uh,
I have to see,
and I would fucking see anybody there.
Oh Wow.
That's it.
Okay.
Let's,
let's be fucking honest.
I got to admit Jay Z and Beyonce where there,
I wouldn't want to see Jay z at Royal Albert Hall.
I just wouldn't,
you know,
I was actually picturing led Zepplin there and like the place was so beautiful.
It almost seemed like fucking a offensive,
you know,
for them to be singing the lemons song,
talking about singing poetically about getting your Dick sucked and someplace
that beautiful.
Now I'm not shitting on Jay Z or anything.
I think that guy's a fucking genius,
but you know what I mean?
Like,
I don't think that I,
like if I ever got a gig there,
I'd want to do it just cause zeppelins bend this and Natera,
Jay z and all these guys,
these unbelievable artists.
But for me to go up there,
the I curse,
it just wouldn't be right.
Uh,
you know,
this is why you travel the world is you get you two reasons why you travel.
Okay.
One is to see all the unbelievable things that are out there and realize how
much more there is than what you thought there was.
And then two on the other side is to realize,
you know,
as you start to get homesick,
why you love where you live.
Because that definitely happened because I got to admit,
I fucking went hardcore with the food over there.
I kept getting the traditional English breakfast,
that traditional Irish breakfast.
I got a traditional Scottish breakfast and I'm telling you,
dude,
it's fucking like how those people are still walking around past the age of 40.
It's fucking unreal.
Traditional English breakfast was eggs.
A sausage or bangers is a column.
Um,
Bacon Bacon is more like Canadian Bacon,
where it looks like you took the zest of a pig
with a big greater,
and just took a fucking shingle of pig and throw it in,
throw it into a frying pan.
So you got the fucking sausage,
the shingle of pig,
and then you had luck,
pork and beans.
And then,
uh,
I dunno,
something else,
Eh,
I got to tell you all that fucking pork,
basically two helpings of pork,
three helpings of fucking pork,
sausage,
Canadian Bacon style to the 10th power in pork and beans with eggs.
And then toast,
you know,
then you have a cup of tea.
And a,
I got to met,
dude,
I fucking loved it.
I absolutely loved it.
But like now a week later,
uh,
physically I'm feeling the fucking PA.
Every morning I got up and I got that breakfast.
And,
um,
what else did I do?
I went to a,
I went to,
oh,
the crosswalk there.
I got the picture of the Abbey road thing.
The picture comes out like shit,
because you gotta be standing in the middle of the fucking road.
And,
uh,
I took a video of it.
You got to see it.
It's one of the greatest,
um,
tourist.
I'm not even to do it just to observe it because basically if you're not
familiar with the Beatles,
uh,
you know,
it's a really a shame.
You should listen to their music.
Okay.
That's like the biggest understatement of all fucking time.
But basically,
um,
you know,
Abbey road is basically the four Beatles walking across a crosswalk.
So now everybody,
when they go there,
it was a Beatles fan that has to have four people and take that fucking picture.
And the reality is is they've actually moved the cross walk like 20 feet down
the fucking street scene are walking where they walked.
But anyways,
um,
okay.
The greatest fucking thing is people stop in the fucking crosswalk cause they
want to get the goddamn picture,
which I think actually fucks up the picture because I think they took the
picture where they while walking.
But long story short,
short,
all the poor bastards who live over there have to,
who live in that part of town after deal with that every fucking day.
It's the most annoying tours de thing I've ever seen in my fucking life.
And he got all these people all excited.
Oh my God.
At the Abbey road.
Wait,
let's get the,
I want to be John Lennon and allow,
let me be Paul running around in these.
And then you just listen to these English people beep in the home.
If,
for fuck's sakes,
you're fucking cards.
Beep.
It was awesome.
The whole thing was awesome.
So we're actually getting this almost like 38 minutes in and I have to fucking
meet Bobby to go on a hike.
So I gotta wrap this shit up here quickly.
Um,
so anyways,
did all that type of shit.
Saw Big Ben,
went out,
had some drinks,
had a great fucking time.
And then I did my show and a,
the show at the just theater when went incredible.
Um,
I just had an awesome time,
man.
And I want to thank really from the bottom of my heart.
Everybody who came out in England and London,
Dublin and,
uh,
in Glasgow was fucking awesome.
So,
so basically,
yeah,
we did that.
And then the next day we,
uh,
we flew over to Dublin and the Irish people would just fucking hilarious.
Um,
my show with the sugar club when an unbelievable and a,
afterwards I was hanging out with the crowd.
I had a couple of drinks with people in this fucking guy's like,
this Irish guy comes up to me and he goes,
hi,
love Ya.
Hi.
Didn't even let me budget.
Let me buy you a drink.
Hot it off.
Yeah.
Right.
And he fucking buys me a goddamn drink and then he won't fucking leave.
He says sweaty drunk dude with this.
He looks like he plays in a grunge band.
You know what the fucking hat on and he just won't fucking leave.
And he's drunk and he keeps coming up and he keeps trying to touch my fucking
hair,
which I had moose stop what I have left on top,
right.
So finally he ends up fucking,
he comes out of nowhere with his sweaty drunk hand it fucking like pets.
The top of my head,
another man pet the top of my head.
It's my girl goes,
do what the fuck are you doing?
And she goes,
he goes,
oh,
I'm sorry I touched his,
we've,
no,
I'll tell you something.
I am a fucking asshole.
But when somebody gets me with the good one,
the only reason why I didn't burst out laughing in fucking high 500 foot,
how fucking funny that was a was because he's one of these psychos that if you
give him any sort of,
I wasn't even giving them any of it,
any attention,
he wouldn't fucking leave.
So I actually,
if I actually did,
um,
and then I was laughing later like me and my girl both fucking laugh in that he
said was a weave and it's like maybe because I shaved my head and uh,
when I grew it back I had a lot more hair than people thought I did that he
thought I got hair plugs this or something.
But Oh man,
it was fucking hilarious.
Um,
so anyways,
uh,
that was Dublin that we,
that was only on Dublin like two seconds.
We got this hilarious cab driver and he's driving us to the airport and all,
and by the way,
all these Scottish guys were over there cause they had this huge rugby match and
I totally got into the rugby over there.
They got this league,
the uh,
the six nations league that I think is Scotland,
Wales,
England.
How's it three?
Ireland,
France and Italy.
Uh,
there's only six teams so reminded me of hockey like the fucking original six.
There's not that many players.
He can get to know the teams.
So long story short,
if Ireland won the game the day we were leaving,
if Ireland when the game than they were the champions of the league and if
Scotland lost,
they would be the worst team in the league.
Thus winning the wooden spoon,
wooden spoon,
they actually give you a fucking award.
It's like,
like you don't know that you were the worst just in case you forget in rugby
they give you something called the wooden spoon,
you know,
just so people can fucking rub that.
I think that's brilliant.
Fucking brilliant.
I think it's hilarious because that's such a great way to give like a team shit.
Like take the Pittsburgh pirates,
how many fucking wooden spoons,
what they would be like the New York Yankees of wooden spoons and it's just a
whole nother level to give somebody shit.
So basically when we were over there,
all these Scott's came over to watch the game and uh,
all the Irish people were talking shit.
Oh,
it's just fucking great talking about that there that killed and,
and um,
so I got so amped up by watching these guys give each other shit and I wasn't
getting any American sports that I had when I landed in Scotland the next day I
actually watched the game and it was a fucking great game.
And Scotland won.
They actually won and avoided getting the wooden spoon and Ireland actually lost
the championship because of that.
And I believe France one with,
it's just something wrong about French people winning a rugby contest,
you know,
championship.
Considering the stereotype of them and considering I'd never been there.
Wait a minute,
this guy,
it wasn't Andre that giant French.
The fuck is wrong with me.
I'm such an idiot.
All right,
scratch all that,
whatever.
So I got into it and um,
then my last night there,
I,
um,
I went to a,
the Lyons Theatre in Glasgow,
Scotland and uh,
you know,
I was so tempted to go out there,
but I didn't want to fuck my show up at by pissing everybody off.
But I really wanted to go up and open with,
rather than be like,
hey,
how are you guys doing?
And I really appreciate you coming out cause you don't know who the hell I am.
I really felt like coming out there and just going,
how are you doing?
You're fucking scared.
Wearing could just open it up
just to see what they do.
And I realize halfway through the show that they probably would have laughed,
but uh,
I got great video of all of them be,
uh,
the,
I got the whole crowd saying,
you're,
you're listening to Monday morning podcast.
You're fucking cons.
But she can't understand what they're saying because there's too many of them.
I had my heart in the right place.
Um,
maybe I'll put it up with some actual,
uh,
what do they subtitles underneath it.
He'll watch and know that,
yeah,
you're listening to the Monday morning podcast.
You're fucking coat.
They really leaned into it too.
I'll put the video,
it's all gonna be part of the video,
but I,
I sincerely want to thank everybody who came out to see my shows.
I was unbelievable.
Really flattered by the,
uh,
the reception I got when I was over there.
Like people were actually clapping,
like they knew who I was and it was incredible.
And a,
that was another thing that I learned when I was over there was the,
uh,
like the different levels of fame.
Like over here I have,
like I say,
I have notoriety.
That's where I'm at,
you know,
second degree notoriety.
Like every once in a while someone was like,
Hey,
you're the comedian guy.
Right?
Eh,
thank you.
Funny.
I say,
yeah,
he used to be on,
you're on that show,
right?
Once you on that show.
Yeah,
yeah,
it was on the show.
Um,
but just to go over there and see,
I started like John Mayer had a sold out show at Wembley Stadium and added a
second show and I was like,
wow,
that fucking dude,
his famous.
Okay.
And um,
you know,
and we get into the entertainment game and as a performer and you start,
trying to sell tickets,
you know,
when the first time you sell out a fucking comedy club,
you can't believe it.
And just to see someone to be able to move that amount of tickets on the other
side of the fucking world.
It's unreal.
For those of you unfamiliar with Wembley Stadium,
this is how big it is.
Evil Knievel did a stunt there.
He fucking jumped over like,
like 30 buses,
London double deckers.
Granted,
he didn't fucking make it,
but just picture how fast you'd have to get a motorcycle going today.
Forget about a motorcycle 40 fucking years ago at 35 years ago.
That probably weighed two tons.
Okay.
And he bet he cleared the buses.
I think he landed on the last one.
That's a,
that's some footage right there that you might want to check all you x game
people cause he's the fucking father,
all of that shit.
Um,
so anyways,
John Mayer sold that fucking place out in these,
these,
he's got another one coming up,
added a show there.
So I was really a humbled going over there and um,
and I'm looking forward to coming back again going to a concert at Royal Albert
Hall,
going to a rugby game and either Scotland or uh,
a fucking Ireland and just coming through all those again.
I definitely want to build up a following over there cause I had a great time
after actually actually after my,
my Gig in the Lyons theatre,
I went over to um,
this,
this comedy club and dude,
it was fucking hilarious.
Uh,
we walked in there and we will to the host of the show and the guy is speaking
English and we cannot understand 80% of what he's saying.
So we are laughing along with the crowd,
not at the jokes.
Just fucking Hydra.
Jane did a fucking hot,
it's like what you guys remember that one when in snatch,
when Brad Pitt played that Irish character,
you couldn't understand this was the Scotland,
Scotland version of that.
And I met this comedian Kevin Bridges,
who's I guess huge over there.
Not even guess.
He is huge over there afterwards,
we haven't a couple of pints.
And I started talking about the word cunt and I was too drunk.
I wish I filmed it listening to these guys talk about the word cunt,
the way they say it now.
It would've been so perfect on this podcast at some point.
I have to,
I have to interview one of those two guys on this podcast.
But,
um,
I was sitting there going,
yeah,
I can't wear like blown away how you guys can just say cunt and it's not
offensive.
And they're like,
yeah,
I'm thinking like high.
Anybody says that when they come over here,
have a blah,
blah,
blah and all this shit.
Right.
So I was talking to him,
Mike.
Yeah.
You actually use it as like,
like a compliment.
You say stuff like,
Oh,
you know,
he's,
he's a good client and the other guy goes,
he goes,
oh,
he's a good aid,
current top couldn't,
so they,
you'd go there,
there's a new expression for you.
He's a top cunt.
I think that's one of the greatest things I've ever heard.
So I'm saying that these guys,
um,
ah,
fuck,
why did they film,
you would have loved this shit if you,
if you're a standup geeky didn't want to you and you just want to see like where
would trade notes like I was saying,
so I go,
so what is basically the seaward,
what is the word you can't say over in Scotland?
And he said,
uh,
spastic is what he said spastic.
And he tried,
he was explaining it to me,
but,
but granted we were both fucking shit faced and I could barely understand what
this dude was saying when we were all sober.
Right.
But he was,
I guess it means I couldn't figure it meant some form of like a retarded slash
vegetable and like,
I dunno,
like that.
They just don't,
you just,
you don't talk about that stuff over there.
If you do,
I guess it's literally needle going off the fucking record player.
But,
um,
so I thought that that was really a,
I thought that that was an interesting,
what else?
Oh,
here's something you guys better brace yourselves for as far as pop culture
thing that I saw over there on their American idol over there.
Um,
there's a,
there's these,
these twins and they got these high top fades like that dude from kid and play.
Um,
I think it was play the light skin dude,
right with the fucking high top for that.
Fucking beyond that.
The eraser head fade,
right?
Two white kids,
they have that do,
they're twins named John and Edward and they go by the name Jedward I sweat
and they're really into vanilla ice.
They think vanilla ice is awesome.
And the reporter was going,
you know,
people kind of ridiculed him and they're like,
oh,
but when he freestyles,
he's lethal.
So I didn't even have to hear what the fuck they sing.
I just know that some shit is so bad.
It's fucking awesome.
So I'm just just telling you to get prepared for that because I think that that
could go global.
That's it's like the perfect storm of fucking awful.
So do you remember you heard it here first in the states.
Watch out for Jedward.
Look them up if you have to.
Um,
all right.
What?
50 minutes into this thing.
I got to fucking rap this fucking thing up.
What did I want to talk about?
I have any fucking,
any other stories,
whatever.
This is just the English podcast.
I'll give you one fucking overrated,
underrated thing that's really annoying.
The shit out of me is this whole thing that when you're going to get a fucking
Burrito,
all right,
or a Taco and they ask you what toppings you want and you get whatever toppings
you want,
then all of a sudden,
if you want to get Guacamole,
this whole bullshit,
that guacamole's extra.
Oh,
that's 50 cents extra.
That's a dollar extra.
Like avocados are fucking rare,
maybe on the east coast.
But I gotta admit I got a two friends of mine who own houses out here.
They got fucking avocado trees in their goddamn yards.
They just,
it's one of those things where just like diamonds,
I always,
you always hear that rumor that you know,
diamonds aren't really rare.
They just say they are and they just control how many go out.
That's what they're trying to do with fucking guacamole.
I put up with it.
It was one kind of fucking food.
I didn't give a shit.
I paid extra for the Guacamole.
I didn't give a fuck.
And you know what I did?
I came by,
became part of the mechanism that created that new corporate fucking current way
of uh,
making extra money.
And I'll tell you why,
because you know what?
I got a breakfast sandwich she other day and Bacon was extra,
you know,
like all of a sudden that's as big fucking commodity.
So you can add that to your fucking list of over priced overpriced fucking
bullshit.
Disposable razors locked up behind the fucking counter,
like their jewels,
orange juice,
guacamole,
and fucking now bacon self.
This is what we gotta do.
Everybody,
the 14 fucking people,
if they say it's extra,
be like,
you know what,
that I don't want it.
Why don't you sit on your fucking bacon?
Let's smell it going bad.
That's it.
I'm not playing fucking ball.
Only time I'm fucking getting guacamole's on home and I'll make it myself.
Or if these fucking cunts don't charge me any extra money,
but you know what they'll do,
right.
You know what that though to make,
all right.
It's not extra anymore,
but the fucking Burrito is 50% more and they'll play on nine
11 because of nine 11.
They always win.
Here's the last thing I want to tell you.
This is the one thing I loved about Scotland.
You know they say whores over there.
Yeah.
They say cars.
Okay,
these fucking hours doing drugs.
The floor was the flour.
I'm fucking up the accent.
All these fucking hires doing drugs.
Hers Pours Hat Jelly.
They said I fucking loved it.
I loved every fucking second of it.
Um,
that's it.
That's the end of the podcast.
I got some shit I got to fucking do.
I apologize that this thing was so late,
but I'm telling you,
you know good things come to those who fucking wait.
I think this was a great podcast.
I'm going to pat myself on the back.
Listen to this.
That was make,
it's really fucking the back of my neck,
my spine area.
That fucking hurt.
All right,
you guys have a great week.
God bless and don't worry.
So a little rough time here.
It's sort of a podcast,
recession.
We're riding our way through it.
All right.
I'll talk to your fucking constantly.